واخيرا وبعد طول انتظار طرح الفنان المصري
رامز جلال البرومو الخاص ببرنامجه الجديد
رامز نيفر اند الذي سيعرض في رمضان الله
يستر من رامز دائما نيفر اند اظهر وقوع
عدد كبير من نجوم الفن والرياضه في مصر
والوطن العربي ضحايا لهذا المقلب ومن
بينهم محمد رمضان واحمد السقا ومحمود
ومحمد فؤاد ومحمود عبد المنعم
ودون ان يظهر تفاصيل المقلب تا وعد رامز
جلال ضيوفه بامرين وليس امرا واحدا حيث
ظهر وهم يصرخون بسبب ما يتعرضون له فاستمر
الملفت هو قيام احمد السقا بقدم راس ثعبان
صغير دون ان يكشف البرومو عن السر وراء
هذا المشهد وهو ما سيظهر في حلقات
البرنامج البرنامج جاري تصويره في مدينه
الرياض بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه برعايه
الهيئه العامه للترفيه